I'm Caroline hide at the Dublin web
summit and I'm now joined by co-founder
and CEO of oculus is Brendan read to
talk all things virtual reality Brennan
where are we now in terms of virtually a
reality well we like to say that in the
past it's been day 0 we are still just
building prototypes and developer kits
and working up towards the consumer
launch of virtual reality of oculus
we're now very close to day one which
will be the consumer launch so we have a
feature prototype here Crescent Bay that
we've been showing we announced that a
cross connect and it really starts to
meet that quality bar that we believe
needs to be for consumer VR come to
oculus so VR long term is going to be I
think they're in a lot of different
industries I think it will affect
medical and architecture and military of
course there'll be all kinds of
different applications in the early days
it's going to be very very centered
around gaming it's built by game
developers we're all most of us are from
the game space it is the kind of heart
and soul of the core technology is a 3d
game engine that you're looking around
inside of and this is full of time if
you think of the matrix so we try to set
expectations that's always something
that's really important setting
expectations for how good the quality of
the experience is the developer kits
leading up to the consumer v1 what this
roadmap is for adoption user adoption
we're not expecting us to be 10 20 50
100 million people in a very near term
all right so we're going to welcome you
back now yeah
so what do you think i have to say i'm
not a gamer and that's amazing that's
really amazing did you you've started to
feel like you were there I don't I mean
you're reacting and you can feel
yourself you're sort of rationalizing it
you're saying to be ridiculous you can
move this isn't real but you still your
first instinct is it is real okay this
is actually quite terrified and it has
tricked the back your brain and it's
only a matter of time but took before
you start to believe the whole thing is
you know a virtual place you can go